[Music]
down North is about Second
Chances we are heroes providing food I
mean making a change sling
P we just thankful for down nor
pizza and uh welcome to
[Music]
Philadelphia
we in Strawberry Mansion North
Philadelphia Philadelphia has one of the
highest incarceration rates in
America and the state of Pennsylvania
has the most state prisons in the whole
entire United States recidivism in North
Philadelphia is very very high so people
are constantly filtering in and out the
system the preschool to prison pipeline
where you're betting on these people to
end up in
prison the simple dictionary definition
of recidivism is when you recommit a
crime and you go back to prison however
you don't actually have to recommit a
crime to go back to prison something as
simple as forgetting to tell your parole
officer that you got a better job and
they finding out that you work somewhere
else that's a direct violation on
probation of parole the state releases
you out here waiting for you to [__] up
and go back to jail the system is rigged
and the average citizen doesn't know
about it they just thinking like oh he's
messing up it's like no they keep you
you caught up in the spider Weare all
these little towns in Middle America
that have no industry are surviving off
of jails being built next to them
everybody got a job at the prison
everybody works off for the backs of us
a lot of times folks are just forced
back into the system because they can't
get hired trying to get a job when you
have a record it doesn't matter what it
is they put something have you been
convicted of a felony and if you say no
you're lying if you say yeah you're not
going to get the job
anyway I often worked in kitchens where
I had to lie about my past where I went
to the Art Institute to become a better
chef but they look at my resume and they
says oh you worked at se Greensburg what
were you doing there I was the cook
there but I don't tell them that I was
incarcerated and I was the cook there
but who wants to lie everybody has some
type of skill it's just a matter if
you're able to put that skill on the
Forefront and actually show people what
you got and these guys is looking for a
[Applause]
chance come on in welcome in down North
SL
P the mission is simple at down North
Pizza we provide a second chance for
people who have been formally
incarcerated through opportunities like
employment housing therefore they don't
get recycled back into the system in the
industry they call this the crown the
cheese Crown but since we combat
recidivism we can call it the cheese
fence down North pizza was inspired by
the Detroit style square pizza however
we put our own twist on it and birth our
own North Philly style
pizza there's a Nostalgia about us
growing up eating pizza the whole square
pizza elos was like a big thing growing
up flavor regulator as far as our
signature pizzas as far as the concepts
of it like Mike is a mad man he'll have
the sweet with the salty with the spicy
it's like wow this that North sauce it's
coming through a supermarket near you
that's a first we Feast exclusive sweet
spicy salty flavor fully
regulated I want to give you as much
flavor as I can in every bite so that's
why I use different ingredients that
aren traditionally Pizza ingredients
from Curry to Berber spice and it's just
like the stuff the flavors that I enjoy
on the regular on dishes I just wanted
to incorporate that inide Dale North
menu on piezas that se Greensburg I was
cooking for 2,000 people twice a day so
I had to pay attention to like like
dietary restrictions for a lot of people
there 2,000 people at the jail 400 of
them might have diabetes like got to go
easy on the sugar 500 of them might have
hypertension so I got to go easy on
assault I definitely never folded under
that type of pressure it was just like
hey this is easy a kwalk so we have
signature pieces as far as down North
they're all named after songs from
Philadelphia artist it's our track list
everybody else got a menu we got a track
list all right well we have here this
the rock the Mike this is named after a
famous Philadelphia song beanie seagull
freeway beef pepperoni four cheese blend
nor
sauce parmesan garnish this is our top
selling pizza right
here still like I said I'm doing a lot
of dough so our dough we do every day I
come anywhere between 1 2 a.m. in the
morning and stay until everything is
finished more is priceless anybody will
be lucky to have them working for you
because he gives it his all like he
didn't chopped off a finger about down
North you know what I mean like that's
my guy so that right there as far as
that big dispenser I'm in here hand
squeezing lemons so I have my son Amari
and Elijah that's the future of down
North this my tattoo for my
[Music]
kids are you
serious y'all got to put that in you got
to y'all got to put that
got miles in the ding up you call me
yeah it's it's a lot of work and
everything we do we put love into it
we're not just here make a pizza just to
just to make it and to sell it we talk
to people when they come here I want
them to feel the love so we're all
previously incarcerated we're just like
pushing as far as a narrative as far as
change that's excellent that's really
excellent I mean we walk around with
that not yeah that's I
want yo you ate all the wings I ate he
we going to fight good googly
moogly it's that good we can't find
parking spot we just got to pull over
and eat can't wait it has a different
taste when you take that first bite
you'll know like you have to come and
try it it just can't explain it and most
of all that they giving it back to North
Philadelphia the community that they
grew up in and they giving for the
neighborhood so it's it's most important
that they're doing that and I'm thankful
for that thank
you when I was released from prison I
had a hard time finding a place to live
because of my record those obstacles of
finding a place that would let me live
there with a background right that was a
tough pill to swallow so what down North
is doing is helping them find those
resources for guys so they can come home
and they can assimilate back into
society because without those resources
now you out here in your homeless
downtown because there nowhere for you
to live me understanding that and then
having these apartments these guys are
working here they having trouble find
find in a place let's utilize these
apartments for
[Music]
that
Mingo good
morning good
morning oh man Ruby that's my baby
daughter she's 7 years old that's my
whole heart right there in a human form
as they say you want a little pepper on
eggs no all right
man
go I was locked up on February 15th and
Ruby was born March 15th the first time
I ever like held her my mom brought her
into the visiting room and I held her
and it was like I fell in love with her
and I knew that I really had to put an
effort into staying on this side of the
wall let you man go love you
[Music]
too pop block ITP
take
oh it's like walk in the yard so that's
a term as far as for people that's you
know been carcerated usually make a
Walky or S you know like find friends
and as far as with us we all come from
like around the same backgrounds been
misguided made made some bad choices in
our life which don't Define who we are
just Define as far as what our action
was it's a good Brotherhood it's much
more than a job eron cook your fingers
you ain't never work in the kitchen if
you ain't getting burnt at least one or
two times the Brotherhood that we have
in this kitchen this family this
camaraderie is definitely therapeutic
for everybody something that we look
forward to you need somebody you can
relate to you need somebody that's
relatable and somebody that Shar the
same experiences with you I can't go
talk about some of the stuff I've been
through with my grandmother or one of my
my my aunts cuz they never been in that
situation it might see it just sometimes
it just be
some I feel as if we help each other
just by being there and being there
somebody to talk to a lot of people
don't relate to ordering commentary or
walking the yard for years or not being
around your loved ones and missing them
we get along outside of work this isn't
just something we do inside of work I
talk to these dudes on the phone for an
hour at a time we go bowling we go out
to eat all the time we like real live
Brothers in here we call it B that's all
we do all day we
big today somebody turn the lights
that's that's trauma see you trying to
start
something
welcome to the orchard the PDP Orchard
is the Philadelphia Department of
Prisons Orchard which is located on
Prison grounds on State Road in the
Northeast part of
Philadelphia birds chirping early in the
morning just put you at ease is being
out here in nature me and my thoughts
you can actually think without having to
like watch your back or watch what's
going on anywhere it's a beautiful
feeling to actually be alone with
yourself and
self-reflect across the bed right here
we have Heather leech hey guys our great
friend she reached out to us invited us
up here and we've been down ever since
yeah it's been magic ever since she's
our
Jedi other actually heard our interview
on NPR and popped in the next week like
yo I heard you guys and what you're
talking about I have a Orchard and we
like yeah we're we we're down for that
we want a farm she's like on State Road
we like what are you talking about I've
been on State Road for years yeah I
never seen an orchard up
here I thought we could plant some
collards in kale today okay so what kind
of Collard we got we have so many types
so we always try to grow a good variety
so this is my favorite one actually it's
the big daddy greasy green collards
doesn't that sound good yeah that sound
heavy planting seeds and actually seeing
them grow I think is something very um
therapeutic about actually nurturing
something into existence just having
like a supply of food right at your
hands that you actually help nurture
it's a dope thing oh these CH is going
to be
crazy sometime we go straight to the
fryer nothing like a fresh chicken egg I
can get used to this put me on the farm
any day yeah I'm not reaching in her
butt
though Garden out here growing all this
fruit that can't go inside the building
for for whatever reason it's a lot of
red tape they won't tell us why we can't
feed the jail in the Jail commissary
sucks it's full of sodium it's full of
sugar and you see people blow up if you
don't take care of your body people
leave with
diabetes and hypertension and all types
of mental health issues the heartfelt
part is like seeing the guys at those
windows you know and just looking at
them it's like they locked up in the
cage they're hoping that one day when
they get out they're just afforded
opport to be productive if we can kind
of break down some of those barriers
that they have to overcome and those
hurdles we'll make the world a better
place hey Nory chips you ever had a Nory
chip you never had what's those it's all
right I'll take it off for you I'll put
it on the side for you how about that we
actually looking to make change and
since we was looked at the villains why
not be the heroes I would love for down
North to become a spot in every city cuz
every city has a North Philly where
people are trying to recover from the
carceral system we're breaking the
stagma that formally incarcerated are
criminals waiting to reoffend down Earth
is showing that we have the skills and
hard work to contribute positively in
the community 5 10 years from now you'll
have down North pizza and La Florida
Texas similar markets around the United
States to help these neighborhoods that
we feel like is definitely needed as we
continue to grow cuz we feel confident
that if we take it anywhere we have the
same
[Music]
effect
Pizza demo take one
Mark I got an album coming out in two PS
called is Lonely at the Top get St
us guys that on these are Hy hores
they're like the best farming tool ever
from everything from planting to night
fights in the garden
exactly I don't know if a suckerfree
environment that was it oh we good we
done yay One Tap right that's it we
[Music]
done